- So we think that y'all
see each other all the time.
'Cause you're in a movie
'cause we're dumb and like
but have y'all seen
each other in a minute?
- We haven't seen Xochitl,
this is the first time
I have seen Xochitl.
- That's for su... since we filmed
I mean, I've seen him like
I've seen you like all the time,
but yeah, I haven't seen
you guys in so long.
- I haven't seen you since England.
- Yeah.
- Wait, you've had a
birthday since then, right?
- Yeah.
- Happy birthday, happy late birthday.
- Yeah thank you.
I'm 16 now, that's crazy.
(audience clapping)
- I mean,
It's incredible I was telling her during
when we were playing it.
And I was like 16 years old
in this role of a lifetime.
I'm just like you are
living your best life ma'am.
But I was like yeah.
This is incredible.
- It's pretty crazy.
I'm just so lucky to be here.
- Well you're very talented.
And Right when I said
that it was so funny,
Elizabeth was like she's incredible in it.
And I'm like, so I'm so excited to see it.
But I have to say this in a minute because
in my lifetime
I've never actually met
a human named Benedict.
And I have two on stage right now.
And I just think that's amazing
that you both found each
other in the same film.
- Yeah
- It's this?
I mean, does anybody know a Benedict?
Nobody knows a Benedict, right?
Yeah, It's just not.
- The Pope.
(laughing)
- Yeah. Okay.
- There was a Pope called Benedict,
not that long ago.
- Okay.
But I'm like, do you know the Pope?
I'm just saying, do you know?
- Personally you mean?
Yeah, I guess that's, a harder code.
- It's not a common name.
It's like Kelly or Elizabeth, you know?
So I was just like
it's amazing that you found
each other and there's well.
- What's even more amazing
is he's called Benedict Wong
and he's playing Wong.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] I know, I love that.
Yeah, we joked about having
the Wong for Wong campaign.
- Yeah (laughs).
- We've known each other for a while.
We knew each other way before this job.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh Wow.
- But we've never worked.
We'd never had two Benedict
moments on set until this one.
- No not yet.
No.
- Yeah.(laughs)
- Not until Marvel.
- Until now.
- Look what they did,
but you've said
that Marvel is now
entering like a phase Wong.
So what does this mean?
I like phase Wong by the way.
I'm into it.
- Oh, I mean you say one drunk thing
in a bar and then it just
chances, you know, doesn't it?
- What, can you just handle
that giant octopus thing?
- Yeah, that was, that was a
true story, that by the way.
(laughing)
Yeah, I basically had
an email of Kevin Fergi
that he was saying, this
is fast becoming the WCU
So I sort of joke
that it's phase Wong at the moment,
but yeah.
- I love it.
I'm a huge fan.
I was literally talking to my mom
and sister last night
about interviewing y'all
and we all are such huge fans
and like we love Doctor Strange.
We're very excited.
She was like, I love him
just at high, so high.
So Xochitl so you play a new
character, so America Chavez.
So would you describe her?
How, would you describe her?
- I mean, you know,
she's amazing,
she's strong and powerful.
She can travel multiverse using, you know
star shaped portals that
she can punch and kick.
- I love that.
- I'm just so happy to be playing her.
It's pretty crazy.
- And this is like a new character
'cause I wasn't into comics
like when I was young.
So this was a new character, right?
- Yeah.
- They're introducing.
It wasn't like from the...
I love that.
- Yeah, what's so great
about her is that she is 14
which is younger than any of
the versions in the comics.
So in this movie we
kind of get to have like
a new introduction to her and
you know, that's exciting.
- I know I'm very excited.
I'm 40 years old and owning it.
I don't even care.
Don't care.
- Yes
You know what?
It's the little things in
life that make it happy.
So Xochitl what's been the coolest thing
about being in the like Marvel world.
- Well, I mean, of course working
with these award-winning
actors, I mean, that's
I'm pretty lucky, but I
mean I used to have them
as action figures, you know?
So it's pretty crazy to be like
friends with these people and then you--
- Do you have your own now?
- [Xochitl] Well now it's full circle
and I have my own action figure.
I mean, there's my tiktok
- That's so cool.
(audience clapping)
I mean,
Benedict was there when I first saw it.
I was on set, when she first
got it and I, you know, I
I get reams of approvals for figurines
and action figure all the rest of it.
So I'm like, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yes, alright.
More plastic in the world, great.
She gets it and goes
Oh my God
- I know and I'm like I'm crying.
- And she bursts into
tears I thought, oh God
the joy of it, you know,
it's such a moment, amazing.
- It's kind of cool to
like you see it through
like a different eyes.
It hasn't had that happen yet.
- It's very much the dynamic
in the film at times.
I mean, she's a very powerful character
but there's a sort of cynicism.
- Yeah.
- She crushes that up a little bit.
So...
- I love that.
So you don't put up with this crap.
Is that your character?
I love your character.
- She's sassy
- Okay, I like it with the head shake.
- It's the head.
So, Benedict W , sorry
I heard that you like to
DJ onset, is this true?
And what's your favorite music?
- I do like to DJ, if
you need to employ me.
It's DJ OB Wong dot dot dot
Can you feel the force?
- Did you say DJ OB Wong?
- That's amazing.
The story about people
Sean is just DJ OB Wong.
So we--
- It's another 10.
- So we share a makeup trailer.
Don't we?
So we're always kind of
putting the tunes out
- Like almost every morning.
We would like play really like...
- What kind of hype music
are you listening to?
It's not Johnny Mitchell.
So, what are we listening to?
- Also lots of Lizzo.
- Ooh, I like it.
- Olivia Rodrigo of course
- Love the whole record.
- Well, she's always
trying to pull me into one
of her tiktok moves, but, I think health
and safety got involved.
'Cause I was really, I
put my back out, so...
- I Think we have an audience
question for the cast.
Where is Cruise?
- Hey.
What's up cruise.
- Hi, how's it going?
- You can stand up, what's your question.
- Okay, so I have a question for you guys.
So, I'm obviously a big Marvel fan
and it has taught me a lot of
really valuable life lessons
but I wanna know what has it taught you?
Like being part of the Marvel universe.
- Ooh, Elizabeth, would
you like to go first?
- Sure.
Well, I think the character I play,
Wanda.
She's made lots of ...
She's very opinionated and through that
has also found herself making mistakes.
And I think it's important
for us to watch people make mistakes.
I mean, I think we do that
pretty well with a lot
of our characters and I
think it's important to
show that kind of process
through working, through suffering
of different kinds from that.
And so, I guess it's--
- [Kelly] it's real.
Yeah, so it's been
I think I've appreciated
getting to explore that
through this.
- Yeah, what about you Benedict C?
- Well you see, yeah.
It's again through the character, I guess.
I mean, through making a
Marvel film, you learn a lot
a lot, to do with patience
and pacing yourself.
- Lots of patience, but
also I think the characters
do always that, you know,
that's, what's great about him.
There's great laughs, there's
great action, there's great
sort of enticement for
a spectacle as you know
but there's also
something of the zeitgeist
or something profound to
take away for me, for him
especially in this one, it's learning that
you're stronger together
than you are on your own.
It's pretty much the lesson I carry away
from this one without
giving away too much.
- Boy, drive that one home for the world.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Listen,
What about you Benedict W?
- I've just enjoyed overall.
What, Marvel do with these
incredible films, you know
it's about inclusion
and how we represent
many
people of colour.
And again, as I talked about, you know
the platform and opportunities
that we have with Shang-Chi
and now we have Ms. Marvel coming up
and everybody gets to
see that they can have a
hero that they can follow.
So...
- Absolutely.
- I love, yeah.
- So it's so important
because I think a lot
of times people are like,
you know, you do, you know
they wanna see themselves,
but also it's important
for other people to see
other people in these roles.
That's, the bigger picture too, is like to
make sure you're seeing
everyone for those kids as well.
Marvel does such a great job with that.
I feel like.
- Yeah.